in the third season of Yellowstone
viewers finally learned the source of
Beth's animosity toward her brother
Jaime a flashback shows they were
closest teenagers and Beth turned to her
brother for help when she discovered she
was pregnant Jaime's solution was to
take her to the abortion clinic that
serves the Region's indigenous
population Jaime is informed that the
procedure will amount to sterilization
for bed but he goes ahead and consents
on her behalf he doesn't even tell Beth
about the consequences when she finally
learns the truth she can't forgive him
time notes that many Native American
women were sterilized legally and
without their knowledge at reservation
abortion clinics in the 1970s but that
practice ended well before Beth would
have been getting her abortion it's also
hard to believe that Jamie would be
allowed to consent for his sister since
he's not her parent or legal guardian
plus considering that the clinic staff
seemed to recognize them as children of
the powerful Dutton family it seems like
they'd at least mention this to Beth
before going through with it